Professor Donald
Kagan: The period in which
the Greek poleis were
left essentially to their own
devices came to an end with the
clash between the Persian Empire
and some of the Greek city
states,
but which came to involve
Athens at the famous Battle of
Marathon in 490,
and I'd like to tell you today
about the rise of the Persian
Empire,
and its conflict with the
Greeks, and concluding with the
account of that battle.
First, some terminology.
The Persians were what the
Greeks called them and that was
appropriate.
They were very close cousins of
the people, who lived right next
to them or among them,
called the Medes.
In fact, the Medes were the
first of that group--I guess we
could call them Aryan peoples.
Again, that's a term that has
been abused throughout the
nineteenth and twentieth
century, as though it was a
racial group.
The term is a linguistic one,
and they spoke a branch of the
Indo-European family of
languages,
which is designated as Aryan,
and that's all that that really
means, but they're very,
very close.
In fact,
the Greeks really couldn't
distinguish between the Persians
and the Medes,
and so they called them
sometimes Medes,
and sometimes Persians.
It really doesn't matter
because, although the Medes took
the lead in forming a national
kingdom out of a tribal society
and were the first to be the
dominant family on the Iranian
plateau where these people
finally settled down,
the Persians then overthrew
them and established themselves
as the ruling group in that
family under Cyrus the Great,
as he was called back probably
in 559.
He was called Cyrus the Great,
because he was a great
conqueror, first making his
tribal associates the Persians,
the dominant force in Iran and
then expanding the extent and
the power of what we can now
call the Persian Empire,
an extraordinary distance.
If we look at the end of
the lifetime of Cyrus,
one man's lifetime,
is when this extraordinary
expansion, much of it,
most of it, takes place.
If you look at the Near East in
the year 550 B.C.
what you find is the Kingdom of
Medea, the Kingdom of Babylonia,
which is the most powerful one
in the Tigris Euphrates Valley,
what is now Iraq,
the Kingdom of Lydia occupying
sort of the western portion of
Asia Minor,
excluding at first the coast,
which was occupied by Greeks,
but which the Lydians then
conquered the Greeks in the
540s--that's the picture.
Then there is the people of
Persia, the Persians themselves
who are of not much account.
But when Cyrus becomes King in
559 he is a member of the
dynasty which is the Achaemenid
Dynasty,
and he conquers his fellow
Aryans, the Medes in about 550,
and very swiftly conquers
Babylonia,
Armenia, Syria,
Cappadocia, which is another
kingdom in central Asia Minor,
and has already expanded this
kingdom to something pretty much
unexampled up to that time.
Now, meanwhile in Lydia,
the dynasty that began back in
the seventh century,
finds that the King Croesus is
the monarch at that point.
You will have remembered,
of course, that Herodotus'
first book pretty much begins
its story with King Croesus,
and his decision to attack the
Persian Empire which is now on
his frontier.
You all remember the story that
Herodotus tells so charmingly
–
the story of how Croesus
decides he wants to conquer the
Persian Empire,
consults the Oracle of Apollo
at Delphi to see how he's going
to make out;
the oracle gives a
characteristically enigmatic
answer, but he doesn't recognize
the enigma.
He says, "What will happen if I
cross the Halys River," that's
the boundary between Lydia and
the Persian territory.
The oracle answers,
"A great empire will be
destroyed," and of course he had
in mind, destroying the Persian
Empire.
Instead the Persians destroyed
his empire, and of course,
that shows you you've got to
ask the right question and keep
answering it until you get an
answer you understand.
Well, Croesus attacks in 547;
his capital of Sardis falls
into the hands of the Persians
in the next year,
and so now the Persians are in
control of the Lydian Empire and
on the frontiers of the Greek
cities on the coast of Asia
Minor.
The conquest of those cities
takes place in the years 546 to
539;
539 is a very big year for the
Persians, because in that year
they conquer the city of
Babylon,
and thereby gain control of all
of Mesopotamia,
another one of the major
expansions of this vast empire.
The successor to Cyrus is
Cambyses and in the years
between 530 and 522,
he conquers,
amazingly enough,
the Kingdom of Egypt.
Perhaps the oldest,
but if not, almost the oldest
of the kingdoms of that region,
fantastically wealthy,
and in its own right formally a
great empire.
Now, if you stop in 522,
when Cambyses dies,
you see that the Persian Empire
extends on the west from the
Aegean Sea and the Mediterranean
Sea to the west,
all the way to the Indus River
in what is now Pakistan.
From the south really to what
is now Sudan at the southern end
of the Nile River,
and up north to include the
European coast of the Hellespont
and the region and the waters of
the straits,
and the European coast of the
Aegean Sea and he comes right up
as far as the Danube River,
nor is that the end of what he
would like to do.
Cambyses launches an
invasion of the territory beyond
the Danube, which was not in the
shape of any kind of a national
kingdom yet,
just an area filled with
different kinds of tribes which
the Greeks called Scythians,
pushing all the way back into
Russia, all the way back to the
Caucuses Mountains and perhaps
beyond.
These horse-riding,
tribal people called the
Scythians, who didn't even
really engage in agriculture,
but were still in the business
of living off herds of animals.
Well, the expedition goes
forward, and it ends up gaining
the straits in Macedon,
as I told you before,
or I should have told you those
names anyway.
The story is told that one of
the generals of the Persian army
is a certain Miltiades.
Miltiades was originally an
Athenian, but his family had
been expelled in the time of the
tyrant--or rather they had been
sent to govern the Gallipoli
Peninsula,
the Thracian Chersonnese as the
Greeks called.
So, he lived up there,
and then when the Persians came
and took that territory,
he became a subject of the
great king and he became a
general in the great king's
army.
He and some others were
given the task of guarding the
bridges across the Danube,
while the king was chasing
Scythians on the other side.
Well, he was unable to defeat
the Scythians,
who used Scythian tactics,
which is to say,
on cavalry, stayed away,
avoided a direct conflict and
did damage with missiles at a
distance and ran away when they
were about to face a great
Persian army which could defeat
them.
So, he was gone a long time,
and while he was gone,
Miltiades said,
"He'll never come back.
Why don't we just break down
these bridges to make sure he
never gets back,
and then we'll be free of the
Persians."
Well, it didn't work out that
way and the Scythian campaign
didn't succeed,
but the Persian army came back
and Miltiades had to run off and
escape,
because there was certainly a
price on his head,
and he ended up going back to
Athens where we will run into
him again.
So that is the situation
when we get to the turn of the
fifth century.
The Persians are in control,
they have gained mastery of all
the Greek states of Asia Minor.
The typical relationship
between those cities and the
King of Persia was the same as
all of his subjects.
He insisted,
in every case,
that the defeated states who
came under his power should give
earth and water to him as a
symbol of their complete
subjection to him.
There was no kind of
relationship to the great king,
except of one of complete
subjugation.
The Greeks regarded that
relationship as one of slavery.
But as a matter of fact,
the Persians were not harsh
rulers for the most part.
All they required of the
subject peoples was that they
should pay a tribute to the
king, and it was obviously not
one that couldn't be met.
Obviously, nobody likes to pay
a tax, especially to a foreign
conqueror, but it wasn't
something that destroyed the
economy,
and to do military or naval
service at his command and under
his command as well.
So, if you did that,
they left you alone.
At this point,
at the characteristic regime
was to have a tyranny appointed
by the great king of Persia in
each Greek city.
Remember, you should use that
word in its original concept.
It doesn't mean they were harsh;
it doesn't mean they were
particularly cruel.
They were satraps,
the representatives of the king
in the region,
and they had absolute control,
but we don't hear about any
specially harsh treatment of
anybody.
That's the situation,
when we will come very shortly
to the beginning of conflict
between the Greeks of the
mainland and the Persian Empire,
when the Ionian rebellion
breaks out.
But before that happens we need
to go back to Greece and see
what's going on there.
Remember in Athens,
the Cleisthenic revolution has
taken place.
The new hoplite democracy that
I have described to you is brand
new and very insecure.
Fearful that there are enemies
within, some of them friends of
the aristocratic families that
have been defeated and fled,
some of them friends,
relatives of the tyrants whose
loyalty to the new regime is not
clear.
So, that's one fear.
Another fear is that the
Spartans will not accept their
expulsion, the expulsion of
their friends,
but will come back again with
an army to try to conquer Athens
and turn it over to the
aristocrats.
Yet, a third problem,
Athenian neighbors with whom
the Athenians have old quarrels
may take advantage of their
beleaguered situation and attack
them.
So, that has to be remembered.
Athens is in a very
insecure spot,
and Herodotus tells us that in
these circumstances the
Athenians attempt to get help by
sending a mission to the king of
Persia,
asking for an alliance with
Persia as a way of fending off
these troubles.
Of course, the king only knows
one relationship with other
states.
He doesn't know anything about
alliances that have any equality
associated with them.
He asks the ambassadors of
Athens to give him earth and
water and then they can be
friends.
The ambassadors say okay we'll
do that, but when they come back
to Athens, the Athenians are
outraged that they have done so.
They punish the embassy and
there is no relationship between
Persia and the Athenians.
Indeed, what they feared
happens.
The Spartans invade Attica
and as they are doing that,
they are joined by other states
who have their own grievances
with Attica,
Boeotia, led by Thebes,
Chalcis which is a city in
Euboea just to the east of
Attica and Corinth just down the
road on the isthmus.
They are all going to attack
the Athenians,
but it turns out that the
Corinthians balk at this idea,
and what they don't like they
say is the notion of installing
some kind of a tyranny in
Athens.
They have had the experience of
tyranny, they have expelled the
tyranny not so very long ago
they claim,
and they are not about to join
anybody in doing the same thing.
So, that's one source of
division that prevents this
coalition from attacking the
Athenians.
But there's also a quarrel
between the two Spartan kings,
Cleomenes who has been there
before and who very much wants
to take Athens and return it to
his aristocratic friends,
and King Demoratis,
who for whatever reason,
is not willing to do that.
Demoratis loses the
argument, charges are brought
against him and he flees,
and next we will find Demoratis
in the Persian Empire at the
elbow sometimes of the king,
giving him advice as to how to
deal with the situation.
Well, because of these things,
there is no invasion.
The Athenians are now free to
turn against their neighbors who
have threatened them,
against the Boeotian cities led
by Thebes, against Chalcis and
the Athenians defeat their
opponents.
In Chalcis, on the island of
Euboea, the Athenians take away
a chunk of land from the
Chalcidians and plant 4,000
Athenian settlers on that land,
and they do so not as a colony
in the traditional sense,
not as an apoikia but as
what the Greeks call a
kleruchy,
which is this:
these 4,000 Athenians who take
the land, settle there
permanently, but they remain
Athenians.
They are still Athenian
citizens;
they are really functioning as
an Athenian garrison to see to
it that things in Boeotia are
okay.
In this way,
they very closely resemble the
Roman idea of a colony,
which was typically a
collection of veterans after
conquering some other town in
Italy,
they would take some of that
land, give it to Roman
legionaries and let them settle
permanently there as a garrison
on behalf of the Romans.
Well, that's what the Athenians
do in the case of Chalcis.
Herodotus sort of sings an
aria at this point about the
wonders of freedom,
in which he says the Athenians
were no better than any other
Greeks at warfare before they
became free.
But once having liberated
themselves from tyranny and
establishing this new
Cleisthenic regime,
they were able to defeat all of
their opponents,
and so much for Herodotus'
prejudice,
but of course as you read his
history, you will realize that
in one sense at least the
history of Herodotus is a paean
to the wonders of freedom and
the greatness of freedom,
and the centrality of freedom
as the story of the Greeks.
By the way, he also praises not
just freedom,
eleutheria is the Greek
word, but in the case of Athens
he praises its isegoria.
That word really means equality
of speech.
He characterizes this new
Cleisthenic regime not by the
word democracy,
which is apparently not really
been coined yet,
but rather as what
characterizes it,
is that all citizens are free,
equally able to address the
populous in the assembly,
and thereby to take an active
role in their own government.
So he's really praising
autonomy, self government,
not merely freedom from an
alien people,
but freedom within the city for
all the people to govern
themselves.
He thinks that's one of the
reasons why the Athenians have
become so good at warfare,
because of these changes.
Now, a new coalition emerges,
also hostile to this new
Athenian regime;
it includes Athens' old enemy
–
the island of Aegina,
which sits in the Saronic Gulf,
right opposite the Athenian
coast and,
as I say they,
have been fighting each other
now for more than a century,
and quarreling about this and
that.
So, the Aeginetans join with
the Spartans and now they are
openly attempting to destroy
this regime and to replace it
with a return to the tyranny of
Hippeis.
Hippeis has also fled to
the Persians and is protected by
the king, so that,
if the Persians get involved,
they too will want to put
Hippeis on the throne in Athens,
but the Spartans want to do the
same thing, and again the
Corinthians will have none of
that because of their attitude
towards tyranny.
Now, threatened even more
severely, the Athenians send a
second mission to Persia,
and this time the Persian king
makes it very clear that will
require that the Athenians to
put down their newly established
democracy and restore Hippeis to
his tyranny in Athens,
which would make Athens like
the other Greek city states,
the ones that are on the coast
of Asia Minor,
part of the Persian Empire,
and Hippeis in his relationship
to Persia would be the
satrap of the great king
governing his own city,
which was, I think,
commonly what was happening in
Asia Minor on the Greek coast
too.
That's where we are when
the Ionian rebellion breaks out
in the year 499.
The start comes in the city of
Miletus, which was of course a
leading city of the Greeks of
that area for some long time,
a place you will remember that
was filled with new ideas where
we first hear about the kinds of
quasi scientific,
but in any case,
rationalistic revolution that
challenges the traditional Greek
way of thinking based largely on
mythology and on theology,
with pure reason.
I don't want to suggest that
the Milesian philosophers were
without religion.
I'm simply saying they're
introducing something new that
stands on the side of religion,
and when it comes to their
attempt to explain what they are
trying to explain,
the physical universe for the
most part--it really does put
aside religious concepts and
replace them with observation
and reason as the way to do
things.
So, what we are seeing of
course in Miletus is the birth
of philosophy at the same time
as we are seeing the birth of
natural science,
and these do not get separated
until many, many,
many years later on;
they are together.
That's the city where the
rebellion starts.
It has nothing to do with
philosophers;
it has to do with the tyrant of
Miletus, a Milesian by the name
of Aristagoras,
who gets into trouble with the
great king.
He has talked the great king
into an expedition that he
wanted to launch against the
island of Naxos in the Aegean
Sea.
He says Naxos is a cinch;
it's a nice fat place.
They're not ready,
and if we sail now secretly,
I'll be able to quickly take
the island,
and the great king will have
another expansion of his empire,
and of course Aristagoras would
benefit both financially,
and also by the presumed honor
that he would gain from the
great king.
Unfortunately,
the security procedures were
inadequate and what he was up to
got to Naxos before he did and
the Naxians were ready.
He was defeated,
and the great king was not
pleased.
Aristagoras knew he was in a
lot of trouble and so he decided
that this was the time for the
Greeks of Asia Minor to acquire
their freedom from the Persians,
and he was obviously a very
persuasive talker and went
around to the various Greek
cities and was able to persuade
most of them to join in the
rebellion,
which is indicative,
of course, of the fact that
they were not happy in their
position as subjects of the
great king.
So, they rebel against the
tyrants who have been
collaborating with the great
king and this is an interesting
point.
They establish democracies.
Now, as far as we know there is
no democracy in the world,
and there never has been before
the one established in Athens
just a few years ago.
I think there's a lot of reason
to think that the idea of doing
that came from Athens,
and that is easily believable
when you realize that Athens,
as I've told you before,
is an Ionian city just as these
cities, Miletus,
and the other towns that they
get to join them at first,
are Ionian cities,
and the Athenians are
recognized by the other Ionians
as the leading Ionian city.
So all of that makes me think
that it's hard to avoid the
conclusion that it's Athenian
democracy that is the model for
these rebellious Ionian states.
But Aristagoras knows that
he's going to be facing a
formidable enemy in the forces
of the Persian Empire,
and so he goes back to mainland
Greece to seek help for his
undertaking, and the first place
you're going to go,
if you want military assistance
in the Greek world of course is
Sparta, and there indeed he
goes.
Again, charming stories that
Herodotus tells about it;
he goes to King Cleomenes,
and he tells him what he's
trying to do and he tells them
how rich the Persian Empire is
and how if they are successful
in this rebellion they will be
able to seize some of the wealth
in the territory of the Persian
king and won't that be nice for
Cleomenes and perhaps for the
Spartans as well.
Cleomenes says,
"Well, I don't know."
He sort of scratches his head
and he says, "How far is the
capital of Persia from your city
on the coast of the Aegean Sea?"
Aristagoras is a shrewd cookie,
and so he says,
"I'm glad you asked you me this
question."
He pulls out the first recorded
map in all of Greek history,
and presumably unrolls it,
and he shows it.
"You see, here's Miletus and
then here's this royal road and
if you take it down here,
here is Susa,
the capital of the Persian."
He says, "How far is that?
How long will it take me to
march from the coast to there?"
He says, "Three months."
Cleomenes says,
"Stranger get out of town by
dark."
The idea of suggesting to the
Spartans that they should launch
an expedition across a sea,
which will then take their army
three months to march away from
the coast, not to mention from
Sparta,
leaving the city,
of course, open to a helot
rebellion all the time they're
gone,
that is not a very welcome
suggestion.
So, Aristagoras says,
well, you know it's not really
so bad;
they got this good road,
besides I have here some
several minae of silver
that I'm glad to give to you,
you might want to think again;
and he keeps raising the amount
that he's prepared to bribe
Cleomenes.
At a certain point,
Cleomenes' little daughter,
Gorgo, has been sitting there
all the time,
and being a Spartan girl,
she gets up to her father and
says, father ask this man to
leave at once or he will corrupt
you.
Cleomenes accepted the
admonition from his nine year
old daughter and sent
Aristagoras away.
So, the effort to gain Spartan
support in this rebellion
failed.
Well, Aristagoras says,
okay I'll try Athens;
now, Athens of course he's got
a much better shot.
The first place Athens is an
Ionian city, unlike the Dorian
Spartans;
second place Athens sits on the
seashore closer to Persia,
right on the Aegean Sea,
and obviously can feel that
there is a certain danger that
might be coming from Persia in
any case,
just because the Persians keep
expanding and they're now
sitting right on the Aegean Sea.
So, for these reasons,
and perhaps others,
maybe they were already--I was
going to suggest--maybe they
were already involved with
Aristagoras and the rebels of
the Greek cities of Asia Minor,
because of the democracy idea.
That gives me the suggestion
that there's been some
communication.
Anyway, whether that's true or
not, the Athenians vote to send
a fleet and soldiers to assist
Miletus and the other cities in
their rebellion and they
send--well,
I'll come back to what they
send in a moment.
Herodotus decides it's time
to make a point;
he says, this shows how much
easier it is to deceive many
people, rather than one,
because by this count it has
got to be wrong;
there were 30,000 Athenians who
were involved in this decision.
That's certainly far too many,
and they were fooled by
Aristagoras, whereas,
King Cleomenes,
the one man was not.
However that may be,
what the Athenians voted was to
send twenty ships.
Now, some scholars would have
said, only 20 ships.
The "only" is really,
I think, a mistake.
They are led to that by knowing
that later in the fifth century
the Athenians will end up having
400 triremes,
but that's many years later,
that's after a victory over the
Persians.
That's in a totally new world.
Best guess I would have now is
that all the ships the Athenians
had were maybe fifty.
So, sending twenty was not a
trivial contribution.
Why did they do it?
Well, for all the reasons
I've suggested,
they care about the Ionians.
They are their relatives in
their own mind.
Moreover, they are not very
friendly to Persia after the
exchanges they have had with the
great king in which it's clear
the only way to deal with the
great king is to become his
subject,
something they're not eager to
do.
Another thing that we need to
take into account is that the
Athenians, remember at least
back to the time of Solon and
possibly before,
have been increasingly engaged
in trade with the east,
that is to say,
with Asia Minor,
with the Hellespont,
Sea of Marmara,
the Bosporus,
beyond that into the Black Sea;
in other words,
into territory bordering on the
Persians so that they have to
feel that if the Persians are
unfriendly or if the Persians
just do what comes naturally to
them,
they soon may be interfering
with things that we need,
we increasingly need.
The Athenians will be
increasingly dependent on grain
and fish from those waters.
So, all of that can explain
why the Athenians are willing to
take this enormously risky
decision when the Spartans,
of course, wouldn't think of
doing it.
Herodotus has this wonderful
phrase to describe the Athenian
decision.
These ships were the beginning
of evils to the Greeks and the
barbarians.
I guess what he's really saying
is, here we have the beginning
of the Persian Wars,
my subject.
The Ionian rebellion is one
thing, theoretically,
if the Athenians had minded
their own business and not
assisted the rebels,
then there need not have been a
Persian War.
Heaven knows what would have
come next.
But in any case,
I think Herodotus is saying
once the Athenians decided to
participate,
assist the rebellion of their
relatives in Ionia,
this was the beginning of the
Persian Wars for Athens.
Well, the twenty Athenian
ships land in Miletus and their
soldiers march inland very
swiftly,
and reach the city of Sardis,
which is the capital of the
Satrap of Lydia,
which now a Persian province,
and are successful in defeating
the forces that come out against
them and set fire to the city of
Sardis.
So, they've done real harm.
Having done that the
Athenians--forgive me,
I left out a small but
important point.
The Athenians were joined by a
few ships provided by the city
of Eretria, another town in
northern Euboea,
an old time rival and enemy
of--what's that other town up
there?
I just mentioned it a moment
ago;
it's gone right out of my head.
Chalcis, thank you very much.
They're old enemies of Chalcis
and that may account for why
they are eager to help the
Athenians,
because the Athenians have
defeated Chalcis and are keeping
the Chalcideans down;
in any case they do.
A few Eretrians,
twenty ships of Athenians
accomplish this deed of doing
considerable harm to the great
king's position there in Lydia.
Well now,
the Persians launch a thorough
going expedition,
with the intention of subduing
their Ionian subjects and
bringing them back to
subjugation.
Well, it's not all that easy.
This rebellion takes place in
499;
the war against Persia doesn't
end until 494.
What the Persians are doing is
laying siege to the cities one
by one, and taking them one by
one,
and then attacking from the sea
and that was critical.
If they could defeat the fleets
of the Greek cities having
already surrounded them on the
land side,
those cities were out of
business and would have to
surrender.
In 494, the fleet that the
Persians gathered--the Persians
of course were land lovers;
they had no navy of their own,
but they had a very
considerable navy provided by
the Phoenicians,
who were among the earliest of
the sailors of the eastern
Mediterranean,
whom the Persians had conquered
and the Egyptians who had a
naval tradition as well.
So, there was a big Egyptian
contingent, a big Phoenician
contingent, and when they were
under Persian rule,
the Ionians provided ships for
the great king too.
They weren't available
right now;
they were going to be fighting
against the great king,
but that's where he got his
forces from.
They were numerically superior
and they were very good sailors
and horsemen.
So, finally at the Battle of
Lade, off the coast--that is on
the coast of Asia Minor near
Miletus,
the Persians destroyed the
fleet of the Greeks and put down
the rebellion.
Then they took vengeance for
the whole thing by laying waste
the city of Miletus entirely,
burning it to the ground as
best one could do that in those
days.
So, the Ionian rebellion has
come to an inglorious
conclusion.
What next?
What next is determined in
considerable part by the
internal affairs of the city of
Athens.
The Athenians are going to be
the most troubled by what has
happened, and also they have a
reason to be troubled.
The great king like--this is
true of most any great empire,
or any great power that has
been attacked or even insulted
by some smaller state,
you just can't let that go by,
you must punish that action to
deter similar behavior in the
future.
So, the Athenians had every
reason to fear an invasion or
some sort of attack from the
Persians in the future.
I think that is critical for
understanding what's going on in
Athens in these years.
We do have a few glimpses,
just a few glimpses that are
difficult to interpret,
but may possibly make a certain
amount of sense.
It is interesting,
I think, that in the year
496-5, which is to say before
the battle of Lade,
while the rebellion is still
on, the man who is elected the
eponymous archon for that
year is Hipparchus,
the son of Karmas,
a relative of the
Peisistratids,
and he is precisely the man,
who tradition says the first
ostracism was allegedly aimed
at.
What is going on here?
Why is the Peisistratids
Hipparchus being elected at this
point, when in fact,
we know that the Persians have
said that they wish to put his
relative Hippeis back on the
throne?
Why would the Athenians elect
this guy?
Well, the only interpretation
that makes any sense to me,
is that you remember that fairy
tale I told you last time about
the law on ostracism,
and about how I imagined
Cleisthenes telling Hipparchus
that he could avoid a lot of
trouble,
if he would join up with
Cleisthenes.
I think he did,
and I think his election to the
Archonship demonstrates that.
It's still Cleisthenes regime
that is in power.
If Hipparchus gets elected
archon,
it must be because he's on
board.
All of this is hypothesis,
but it seems to me to make
sense.
The next event that we hear
about in Athens that's relevant
to our story is that in the year
493,
the Athenian tragedian
Phrynicus presents his play
called, The Capture of
Miletus.
We don't have the play but we
have stories about it,
including one in Herodotus,
and what the stories say is
that the play showed the scene
of the taking of Miletus and the
destruction of the city by the
Persians,
and that the play was so moving
the Athenians were made so
unhappy by seeing this story
that they took measures against
the playwright for making them
so miserable,
and fined him heavily for doing
so.
What's that all about?
Well, there are various
possible interpretations,
but I think the one that's most
persuasive to me is that
Phrynicus knew perfectly well
that when he put on this play
that it would cause great
unhappiness in Athens,
and great anger.
I think he hoped it would
raise, anger against the
Persians, and it would support
the idea of the Athenians
preparing for war against the
Persians,
either in the likelihood that
the Persians would invade,
or that the Athenians would
have to do something
aggressively against Persia
somehow.
That's, I think,
that's the interpretation that
strikes me as being more
plausible than other
possibilities,
but again, it's only a
hypothesis.
In the same year,
Miltiades comes back to Athens,
having traveled from his home
in the Gallipoli peninsula and
he is--think of it for a moment.
What's his position going to be
vis-à-vis Persia?
It has to be anti-Persia,
because he has betrayed the
king of Persia;
he's obviously got a price on
his head.
If the Persians succeed in
putting Hippeis on the throne,
and making Persia boss of
Athens, his life isn't worth a
nickel.
So, he's got to be anti-Persian
and I think what happens next
has to be understood in terms of
the political struggle in Athens
in which--by no means were all
Athenians convinced that it
would be a good thing to war
against Persia.
I mean it's crazy.
What I want to communicate to
you is the idea of fighting
against Persia now is insane.
The Persians have conquered
most of the known world as far
as the Greeks are concerned.
They have just bashed their
fellow Greeks without a lot of
trouble in Asia Minor.
Why would you want to take
these fellows on?
What you would want is to avoid
conflict with them to try to
find some means of coming to
terms with the Persians.
I'm sure there must have
been Athenians,
and Herodotus says there were,
who would have preferred
accepting Hippeis back as tyrant
and having the Persians be the
real rulers of their land,
rather than all getting killed,
when the Persians decided to
come after them.
So, you've got these two
factions;
one pro-Persian,
one anti-Persian,
and the fact is,
apart from hypothesis,
that Miltiades is brought to
trial in Athens.
The official charge against him
is of having been a tyrant in
the Gallipoli peninsula,
when he was in charge of it
there, and he is in fact
acquitted of the charge,
which may suggest,
if the jury was influenced by
popular opinion and had a
political view,
that the majority of Athenians
were not willing to take the
tyranny back in any
circumstances and were prepared
to fight.
Now that--interpretation again
is hypothesis.
The fact of the trial and the
acquittal are there.
Another interesting event
is that in the 493-2--that was
one big year,
that year 493.
Themistocles is elected the
archon,
the eponymous archon for
the year,
and we shall see that
Themistocles will play a very
large role in the great Persian
invasion of 480,
and he will be a participant in
the Battle of Marathon too,
and Themistocles is a great
champion of the navy.
He has concluded for varieties
of reasons, that Athens must
have a much larger navy than she
already has,
and he also is obviously a
member of that faction that
thinks the Persians will be
coming and that wishes to be
ready,
and is eager to fight against
the Persians.
So, Themistocles is on the
scene and one of the things he
does that looks forward to the
rest of his career,
is that he wants to move the
naval base of Athens from
Phaleron bay,
which is just a beach,
unfortified,
completely open to attack if
anybody comes.
So, the Athenian fleet,
presumably, would be drawn up
on the sands of the beach at
Phaleron,
where you can go swimming to
this very day,
and if those ships are up there
on the sands,
a Persian fleet comes sailing
up they're stuck.
What he wants to do is what
he begins to do,
to make Piraeus,
about five miles up the road
into the port of Athens,
the naval base of Athens,
It has three of its own harbors
readily protected.
If you build walls around them,
if you fortify the Piraeus,
then you have a port that will
be secure against an attack,
and also be a very good base
for moving out of.
So, Themistocles demonstrates
what will be his policy for the
rest of his life in regard to
Athens and the fact that he's
chosen Archon may be indicative
of the mood in Athens,
which is increasingly unwilling
to accept the idea of a return
of Hippeis and of Persian rule,
and is ready to fight about it.
Well, by now the King of
Persia has decided that he must
avenge all that has happened and
he must go after the people who
have done him harm,
Athens number one the little
town of Eretria,
number two.
He takes a great Persian fleet,
accompanied by a great Persian
army, and starts marching along
the Aegean coast,
first the east coast and then
crosses the Hellespont and goes
over onto the northern coast.
He himself is not doing it,
his General Mardonius is in
charge.
He conquers the regions of
Thrace and Macedon on the north
short of the Aegean Sea.
But in 492, while his fleet is
lying off the peninsula that
contains Mount Athos,
one of those terrible Aegean
storms that can come up very
suddenly, does indeed come up
very suddenly,
and pretty well wrecks the
Persian fleet.
So serious is the damage that
the Persians have to abandon
their invasion of Greece,
heading for Athens at this
time.
This, I should point out,
is precisely the route the
Persians will take for their
major invasion in 480,
but for the time being,
that has been put off thanks to
the intervention of the storm,
or as the Greeks might put it,
of the gods.
Now, as the Persians have
actually begun to make their
invasion, the Greek cities are
aware the Persians are coming,
the Persians are coming.
The question is what to do?
Well the Island of Aegina,
which is unfriendly to Athens,
you remember from way back.
They decide we're not going to
be swept away with the Athenians
when the Persians get here,
and they give earth and water
to the king.
They have in fact become
Persian subjects.
At this point,
Cleomenes changes his mind;
he does not want to sit there
quietly while the Persians come
and invade Greece,
and so he now goes to the
island of Aegina,
takes hostages,
delivers the hostages to the
Athenians,
and in so doing creates a
rapprochement,
between Sparta and Athens.
And now the Spartans and the
Athenians are allies.
That doesn't mean that the
Athenians have joined the
Peloponnesian League;
they just established friendly
relations after being at odds
for such a period of time.
There is a quarrel between
the two kings,
as I've told you,
and it's at this time that
Demaratus is sent into exile and
Cleomenes himself comes out very
badly.
So, both kings will be in some
degree of disgrace at the time
of the battle of Marathon.
Well, let us turn then to the
Persian invasion that culminates
in the battle of Marathon.
The purpose is very simple,
to punish those cities that
have insulted and damaged the
great king,
Athens and Eretria,
to restore Hippeis to the
tyranny in Athens from where he
can serve as the king's
satrap,
and surely also,
to gain a foothold in Greece on
the way to conquering all of
Greece.
Why should he want to conquer
all of Greece?
Herodotus tells the story
about his relative,
he tells him,
for God's sake why do you want
to go Greece?
There's nothing there but a lot
rocks.
What is the point of conquering
the place?
It's one thing to conquer all
of these rich places Egypt,
Babylonia--that's fine,
there's wealth there,
there's huge populations,
there's a lot of good stuff.
It's just Greeks and rocks,
why in the world do you want to
go there?
The answer, I think in part,
would be Sir Edmund Hilary's
answer, because they're there,
and that's part of the answer,
because we must understand that
the ancient idea--in fact,
I'm willing to say,
the idea that dominated
thinking about such matters
right down probably into the
nineteenth century in many
cases,
but certainly before the advent
of Christianity was this.
That conquest is good.
It's good to be strong,
it's good to be rich,
it's good to be powerful.
Therefore, it's good to be
stronger, richer,
and more powerful.
If there's somebody on your
frontier, take them over,
and that by the way will make
you still more glorious,
because conquest is glory.
Now, we in the west--that's
not our natural attitude;
our natural attitude is shaped
in considerable part,
whatever your religious
association may be,
by Christianity,
which has been the dominant
force in shaping people's
thinking in the west,
as I say, whatever religion you
belong to, and that aspect of
Christianity that it violates is
the one that's increasingly the
one that's emphasized by
Christians,
and that is the Sermon on the
Mount.
The one that says the meek
shall inherit the earth,
not the strong,
and the tough,
and so on.
The one that says if your enemy
strikes you, turn the other
cheek so he can strike you there
too.
Now, if the Greeks had heard
that, they would have said these
people are lunatics.
Send them away.
Greek morality said,
be good to your friend,
do good to your friend and harm
to your enemies and the second
part is just as important as the
first part.
So, you need to understand
that the sort of the ethical
underpinnings to all of our
natural thinking in the west are
as odd and strange,
and crazy as they can be for
everybody else in the human
race, so far as I can see.
There are exceptions.
I am missing some eastern
religions which have ideas that
are not altogether in anathema
to what I am saying,
but what I'm trying to say is
nobody in the ancient would have
ever had such an idea.
Of course, if you can conquer
somebody who's your neighbor,
you do and so there was every
reason to know that the Persians
were coming.
How many?
We don't know.
The estimate that most people
would accept is somewhere
between 20,000 and 30,000
infantrymen.
So, for the sake of splitting
the difference I always assume
something like 25,000
infantrymen, and some cavalry.
That's very important even
though the cavalry does not play
any part in the actual battle of
Marathon,
but Herodotus makes it very
clear that there was a Persian
cavalry, that the Persians
picked the site of Marathon to
fight in,
in part, because it was a good
place for cavalry to fight.
So, there is Persian cavalry on
board the ships anyway,
alongside the infantry.
The two Persian generals are
Datis and Artaphernes.
They have with them Hippeis.
Hippeis, of course,
must have been all these years
urging the great king to make
some such campaign,
and he probably would have
said, Marathon is the place to
land.
You remember that's the
territory of the Peisistratids,
that's where Peisistratus
landed on his last return to
Athens when he made himself
tyrant,
that's where his people were;
that's where his forces would
gather.
I'm sure Hippeis said what all
such exiles always say.
All I need do is set foot on
the beach at Marathon,
and my people will rise up as
one and join me.
You won't even have to fight in
Athens, because they'll be so
glad to see me back.
This is what King James,
I'm sure, told Louis the XIV
about getting back to England.
One hears that all the time,
but it's a very important part
of this story.
I don't think we can
understand what happens at
Marathon, if we don't know that
everybody thought it was highly
possible that there were
Athenians,
who were eager to restore
Hippeis to the throne,
and would be willing to engage
in treasonous activities,
or to defect from the
democracy, and join Hippeis,
if the circumstances were
appropriate.
So, that's in the back of
everybody's mind or in the
front.
I think when the Persians got
there, their strategy included
the belief that there would be
treason in Athens that would
turn the city over to them if
the circumstances were right.
So, that force starts this
time, not along the coast,
as I told you last time.
It takes the shortest route,
directly across the Aegean Sea,
hopping from island to island.
Stops at Naxos,
remember Naxos annoyed the king
by successfully resisting
Aristagoras' invasion and they
destroy Naxos.
Next they come to the
island of Delos in the middle of
the Aegean, the islands sacred
to Apollo and his sister
Artemis,
a very sacred place indeed for
the Greeks.
What do the Persians do?
They treat the Delians and the
priests of Apollo at Delos with
great respect,
do them no harm;
this is typical Persian
conquests.
They do not impose religions.
Their religion is different
from that of most of the others
in this area.
They are Zoroastrians;
they are sun worshippers of a
certain kind,
but they don't impose their
religion.
They don't interfere with the
They get a very nice write up
in the Old Testament,
if you remember,
because they don't mistreat the
Hebrews,
and they particularly don't
compel them to abandon their own
religious practices as the other
invaders do.
So, what are the Persians
saying by these actions?
They are saying we are not
at war with the Greek gods,
we're not even at war with the
Greeks,
we are simply punishing these
two miscreant towns that have
attacked us.
They then turn to the southern
tip of the island of Euboea,
to the town of Carystus;
the Persians may be not at war
with the Greeks but they expect
all Greeks who are along the way
to behave the way they're
supposed too to the great king,
and so they asked the
Carystians to give earth and
water, the Carystians refuse and
the Persians obliterate their
city,
and take their people into
slavery.
Now, they push their way,
take their sail along the coast
of Euboea to Eretria in the
north,
and now here are 4,000
Athenians settled there,
you remember in a cleruchy.
So, they get their armor on and
they stand in front and prepare
to die fighting for the freedom
of Eretria,
because of their wonderful
friendship to Athens.
Wrong.
The 4,000 Athenians go home to
Attica.
Why?
Well, I suppose the immediate
answer is why not.
But it's an embarrassment,
and Herodotus,
I think we have to realize,
is very friendly to Athens all
throughout his own history.
I mean, there's no doubt that
he spent time in Athens;
he seems to have been a friend
of Pericles in later years.
He was kindly,
although he himself comes from
Halicarnassus in Asia Minor,
but he did spend a lot of time
in Athens and there seems to be
a pro-Athenian cast.
One thing also,
is that many of his sources
were Athenians,
who told the story their way.
So, their answer was the
Athenians were ready to fight to
save Eretria but the Eretrians
said there's no point.
Why should you get killed too;
it's not your town.
Why don't you go home.
If you can believe that,
you can believe anything,
but I don't.
I think the Athenians realized
there was nothing but disaster,
if they stayed,
and they could believe if we
get back to Attica,
we might be able to make a
contribution to defending our
city.
Okay, so now here they are at
Eretria, the Athenians are gone;
it's time for the invasion.
The site of the battle,
where did they go?
Well, they picked Marathon,
as they say in part,
because it's very near Eretria.
Secondly, as Herodotus says,
because it's a good place for
cavalry;
thirdly, as I've already told
you, because it's the stronghold
of Peisistratus,
the place which would be
natural for an army trying to
establish Hippeis on the throne
of Athens;
that's why they're there.
Their plan,
I think, is to go to Marathon.
If the Athenians come out and
challenge them to a fight,
they will crush the Athenians.
But they didn't expect that.
They thought the Athenians
would be afraid,
and that what would happen is
they would stay there in
Marathon,
until they got the news that
there was a revolution in Athens
prepared to turn the city over
to them.
That's what Hippeis,
I think, led them to believe,
and that's what they hoped for.
They were prepared to fight,
of course, but they thought it
wouldn't be necessary.
So, on August 4^(th),
they land in the year 490 at
Marathon.
We know these dates,
because there is an eclipse
associated with this,
which allows astronomers to fix
it pretty precisely.
The Athenians,
of course, when they knew that
the Persians were coming and
that news would have come to
them the minute they got to
Naxos.
Ships would have come to
Athens, so the Athenians were
well warned;
they went to their new friends
Sparta to ask them for help of
course.
This is where there are
wonderful stories;
they sent the great runner
whose name comes down to us in
the manuscripts as Pheidippides,
chances are his real name was
probably Philippides,
but there was an error in the
manuscript.
But we'll call him
Pheidippides,
because that's what the
manuscripts say.
He races to Sparta as fast
as he could go;
it took him less than two days,
where he came to the Spartans
and he said, the Persians are
coming, the Persians are coming,
please help us.
The Spartans said we would love
to come and help you,
nothing would please us more,
unfortunately,
we are in the midst of our holy
religious ceremony the Carnea,
and we are not allowed to leave
our hometown until the next full
moon, which is a matter of fact,
the night of August 11^(th),
12^(th), in other words,
a whole week after the Persians
are going to land.
I can't go speculating as to
what are we to make of this.
Is this just an excuse?
Are the Spartans serious about
this?
Our tendency I suppose,
being modern and cynical,
would be to say it's only an
excuse.
I'm more inclined to think that
they were sincere about it.
It's not that they couldn't
find ways to get round such
things, but they really took
their religion quite seriously,
and it may be that that did
play a role.
Be that as it may,
two things that the Athenians
now know.
They know the Spartans have
promised to come but not for
another week.
Both of those things should be
on your minds as you try to
understand.
Now, Herodotus says that the
Athenian army marched out from
Athens and went to Marathon,
and then they had an argument
about what they should do,
but I don't think that's right.
There must have been a debate.
There had to be a debate in
Athens.
You couldn't take an army out
of town without having an
assembly to argue the question,
should we send an army,
and if we should send an army
how big should the army be,
and having decided that,
who should be in command.
All those things had to be
settled by the assembly in
Athens;
so, that is where the debate
took place.
Some favored defending the
city of Athens.
Now, we don't know how well the
city of Athens was walled,
defended by fortification at
this time in its history.
It may not have had any walls,
but I would be surprised.
But it certainly did not have a
wall that was guaranteed to be
effective against an attack,
and so I think we should
understand that is not going to
be successful.
To stay home and defend Athens
means to allow the Persians to
run all around Attica doing
anything they want,
causing all the harm they
could, remember something over
seventy five percent,
maybe as many as ninety percent
of the Athenians had farms out
in the country,
had houses out in the country
that would have been exposed to
the Persians and so there was
good reason for them not to
think that was a great idea.
The alternative was to send
an army out to allow the
Persians to land,
because they couldn't stop it;
they didn't know where the
Persians were going to come,
but as they heard that the
Persians had landed,
just send an army there and
meet them at the place of
landing.
Miltiades emerges as the
leading figure here.
I mean, he is a general,
but that's not the only reason;
it's because everybody knows
Miltiades is the resident
Persian expert.
He has been a general in the
Persian army,
and so that gives him a reason
to be listened to,
but he's obviously also a
person of great merit and
quality, and proves it at the
Battle of Marathon.
He must have been an impressive
fellow.
So, for all these reasons
whatever his formal position
was, and I think it was simply
one of the generals,
de facto he had much
more influence than others for
these reasons,
and his argument was let us go
out and meet the Persians where
they land.
Other reasons were we don't
want them to be able to get to
the Spartans,
but beyond that,
there was fear that if we stay
home and wait,
and let the Persians do
whatever they're going to do,
every day that passes,
it increases the danger of
treason from those people who
want to turn the city over.
It's also so completely against
the ethic of the Greek warrior,
and I would say more
specifically,
the hoplite warrior.
You don't let your enemy ravage
your countryside.
You don't let them destroy your
farms.
This in a way goes all the way
back to Homer,
the notion of
arête,
a man must have courage,
you must stand up against an
enemy who invades his country,
and then again,
beyond that you move to the
world of the hoplite and you're
talking about defending your
homestead;
all of that argued for going
out there.
So, the modern terminology
I would use to explain what the
Athenian strategy was to go out
and to contain the beachhead,
go out confront the Persians
where they are,
don't let them get inland from
where they land.
So, they do land at Marathon
with about 25,000 infantry.
Now remember,
their infantry are not
hoplites.
They do not have heavy armor.
There are vases that showed the
Persian soldiers at Marathon,
and they are wearing pants,
as I told you,
but they're not wearing any
armor.
Their shield is a kind of
wicker shield,
so that their armament is much
inferior to the hoplites,
and keep in mind too,
that the Persian army has
always been made up of a
collection of subject peoples.
Yes there will be some
Persians, but there will also be
lots of folks who are not
Persians in there.
So, they lack that unity that
the Greeks will have.
Miltiades' plan is this,
there are something like 10,000
Greeks, about 9,000 Athenians,
about 1,000 Eretrians against
let us say 25,000 Persians,
and so as the thing begins the
map here shows you the rough
picture of the field at
Marathon.
Here the Persians landed right
here and had their ships drawn
up at this place.
They had their camp behind here.
This marsh ought to be a little
more over this way;
it's a very serious marsh.
It'll play an important role in
what happens.
The Greeks come out--they
probably came marching in
through this way and here we
have mountains.
This wavy line indicates the
line of the mountains.
Here you have a really flat
plain, but here you have
mountains, and somewhere up on
the hills here there was the
Greek camp near the modern
church of St.
Demetrius.
This little dot reflects
the mound where the dead,
the Greek dead at Marathon will
after the battle be buried,
and that is likely to be about
the place where the main
fighting took place,
which helps us to place where
the actual battle took place,
so the idea of the Athenians
was to try to hold them there as
long as they could.
The Greeks have the upper hill,
the Persians are down below.
If the Persians want to start a
fight, then they will have to
come running up the hill.
Well, that is not a very
attractive proposition and so
the Greeks feel,
let them come for us.
It's our country.
So, they're sitting here.
They've got to do something;
we don't.
Meanwhile, the Persians are
waiting for treason,
so that the city will be
surrendered to them.
A week goes by with the two
sides looking at each other and
doing nothing.
I always like to compare the
Athenian strategy to an old
fashioned football strategy,
which I haven't seen done now
in decades, which used to be
kick on first down and wait for
a fumble.
In other words,
give the ball to the Persians
and let them make a mistake.
I think that's what was in
Miltiades mind.
Well finally,
time passes,
and the Persians realize we
can't sit here forever.
For one thing they're going to
run out of food and water,
for another thing,
the great king will want to
hear something.
Well, how did you do?
What did you do?
We sat there and watched the
Athenians;
no good.
So, the plan that the Persians
made, I think was this,
that they would take--let us
say for the sake of argument,
10,000 troops,
put them on the ships,
load up the cavalry onto the
ships too and send those ships
around Attica to come up to
Phaleron Bay straight into
Athens,
and meanwhile take the 15,000
that are left,
march them up as close as you
could get to the Greeks and fix
the Greeks there,
so that they can't go back and
defend Athens.
So, there's no army to protect
Athens.
So if those guys get off the
ships, come sailing into the
harbor, walk up to town,
it's theirs.
If the Athenians are crazy
enough, from the Persian point
of view, to come running down
the hill or walking down the
hill or whatever to be
outnumbered three to two by
us--and anyway we're Persians we
always beat Greeks,
we've got nothing to worry
about, then let them do it.
So they come.
Now, Miltiades is in charge
on the day of the battle.
He's got the problem that they
have 5,000 more troops than he
has.
He's worried about being
outflanked.
So, what he decides to do is to
weaken the depth of his line
because he must cover the length
of the Persian line.
Well, the danger with that is,
of course, that when they hit
each other the Persians will
break through the Greek line.
So, instead of making it even,
he loaded up the wings and left
the center even weaker than it
would otherwise have been.
His hope and strategy was that
the Athenians would win on the
wings before the Persians could
break through the middle and
then the Athenians could turn on
the center of the Persians and
defeat them,
and just barely that's what
happened.
The Persians did break
through the center but they were
too late.
By that time the Greek wing,
the Athenian wings were
successful and drove the
Persians before them,
the Persians ran away like mad,
but they ran into the great
swamp and that made their escape
much more difficult.
So, the Athenians were able to
kill great numbers of them,
and finally that battle was
over.
Now, the battle was over,
let's imagine that it took a
couple of hours that would be a
long time.
The Athenians had time now to
have a meal, take a little rest,
and march back across to Attica
before the ships could get
there,
and I like to imagine the scene
when it all happened.
The Persians coming around
the last bend of the bay as they
come into Phaleron,
expecting to see a nice empty
beach and seeing the Athenian
army.
I like to imagine with their
left foot in the breakers,
and their shields and spears up
with the sun gleaming off their
shields and blinding the
Persians as they came.
At which point,
you can't force a landing
against an army;
it just can't be done in the
ancient world.
These guys had to go home and
start thinking about what
they're going to tell the great
king.
The Athenians won the battle,
very large casualties for the
Persians.
Only 192 Greeks killed in the
battle and allowed the
extraordinary honor of being
buried on the field where they
fought.
Next day 2,000 Spartans
come marching into Attica;
that proves they were serious
and were told what had happened.
They asked permission--can we
go to the battlefield and look
at it, and there they saw all
these dead Persians and no one
had ever seen anything like
that.
No Greeks had ever beat
Persians before,
and great was the glory of the
Athenians.
So I've described very
inadequately and too swiftly the
battle.
So what?
What is the significance of
this silly little battle 10,000
Greeks against 15,000 Persians
back a billion years ago,
what does it matter?
Lots of folks will tell you
that, especially these days.
But I remember in 1936 there
was a wonderful conference of
pacifists, who met in England,
at which the dominant theme of
the speakers was,
no war ever made any
difference.
What I like about that was that
the place of the meeting was
Hastings.
The battle was seen
throughout the rest of Greek
history, first of all,
as a great victory for hoplites
as opposed to their opponents.
In later Greek history,
when the navy becomes a big
thing, it is the party,
the old fashioned and more
conservative party that thinks
about Marathon as the great
victory,
the day that those hoplite
farmers saved Greece.
The navy guys,
the poor like to think about
Salamis, the naval battle in
480.
It was seen as a victory for
democracy;
it was the Athenian democrats.
Later on I'm sure they were
glad the Spartans never got
there, because they could claim
it as their own,
and as a victory for democracy
as well.
It was also the first,
as I say, Greek defeat of the
Persians.
As Herodotus says,
for up until then even the name
Persians was a fearful thing for
Greeks to hear.
It was a source of
tremendous national pride and
glory for Athens,
and scholars have compared the
impact of the Battle of Marathon
on the Athenian image of
themselves with the defeat of
the Spanish Armada by
Elizabeth's English fleet and
the beginning of the glory of
the Elizabethan Era.
It was seen as a victory for
freedom, because the price of
defeat would have been slavery
in every sense,
as they understood it.
Greek civilization,
and I'll come back to this in a
minute, could have been
strangled in its infancy,
because it is in its infancy.
But again, we ought to pay
attention to those people who
suggest that people like me are
over-embellishing the
significance of all this.
One English statesman said
war wins nothing,
cures nothing,
settles nothing;
the speaker was Neville
Chamberlain.
In 1936 Bertrand Russell would
declare, disarmament and
complete pacifism is
indisputably the wisest policy,
and he urged the gradual
disbanding of the British Army,
Navy and Air Force,
as Hitler was moving into the
Rhineland.
Does victory in war make a
difference?
I would say ask the losers,
the victims,
and the survivors of the
Holocaust.
Ask the descendants of the
slaves in the American south.
Remember this,
if the Athenians had lost at
Marathon--Aeschylus had just
begun his career as a
playwright,
Sophocles hadn't written a
play, Euripides of course hadn't
either, nor had Aristophanes.
Socrates, if I got this
right--Socrates wasn't born yet,
much less Plato,
Aristotle, Phidius.
There was no Parthenon,
none of those glorious
buildings that make us think
about the greatness that was
Greece had been constructed.
There would be no
democracy, because this was the
only place where it had any
existence.
The scientific revolution which
was beyond its infancy in terms
of being new would have been
wiped out.
There would be no memory;
there would be no record of any
of this.
Therefore, no Western
civilization,
no political freedom,
for all these have occurred in
no other culture in all the
years since that time.
That's why I wanted you to know
a little bit about the battle of
Marathon because I think all of
us alive today here owe a very
great debt to the 10,000
marathonomachoi,
the fighters of Marathon who
fought for Greek freedom and for
ours too.
Thank you.